[موسيقى]
هذه التكنولوجيا الجديدة يمكن أن تساعد في
مكافحة covid19 ،
وهو روبوت مستقل يدعي
تحييد الفيروسات
والبكتيريا الضارة ، وقد استخدمت شركة عمر تشابوي ، ومقرها دبي ،
الأشعة فوق البنفسجية
لتنقية
الهواء وتعقيم مياه الشرب لما يقرب من
خمس سنوات
بمجرد إصابة الفيروس التاجي به  وفريقه
بحثوا في طرق لنشر ضوء الأشعة فوق
البنفسجية لمحاربة الفيروس ، لدينا
كاميرا لدينا مستشعر لدينا حالة
طارئة يستخدم الروبوت موجات من
الأشعة فوق البنفسجية
تسمى uvc uvc إنه
طول الضوء وعند هذا المستوى من
القوة يمكن للضوء أن يقتل  الفيروس عن طريق
تفكيكه ، مما يؤدي إلى قتل الحمض النووي الريبي
، وعدم السماح لهم بالتكاثر باستخدام
الكاميرات وأجهزة الاستشعار ، حيث يقوم الروبوت
بتخطيط بيئته وتخطيط مساره
وتحديد المدة التي سيستغرقها التطهير
ولكن قبل تشغيل مصابيح الأشعة فوق البنفسجية ،
يتم اتخاذ إجراءات السلامة ،
لدينا عدسات من الدرجة العسكرية من الأشعة فوق البنفسجية.
لدينا درع للوجه ، لدينا بدلات
وقفازات إذا كان بإمكان الأشعة فوق البنفسجية أن
تدمر الحمض النووي الريبي للفيروس أو البكتيريا ، فقد
تكون ضارة أيضًا
منذ أكثر من مائة عام ، تم استخدام ضوء الأشعة فوق البنفسجية لتطهير مياه الشرب في فرنسا ، ومنذ بداية جائحة 19 الخفي ، تم تجربته في مترو أنفاق نيويورك ، وقد ثبت أن الحافلات ubc فعالة ضد فيروسات كورونا الأخرى لكن الدراسات المتعلقة بشكل خاص بـ cobit 19 لا تزال جارية منذ منتصف مارس ، قمنا بشكل أساسي في مختبرنا وفي مساعينا البحثية بعمل أي شيء سوى الأشعة فوق البنفسجية للبدائل الفيروسية لـ cobit وفقًا لأبحاث واختبارات جيمس مالي من قبل المعاهد الوطنية الأمريكية للصحة ساعد ضوء الأشعة فوق البنفسجية في إزالة التلوث من آثار السرقة 19 على أقنعة التنفس n95 ، يحذر مالي من أن الأشعة فوق البنفسجية فعالة فقط مثل جرعة الضوء التي تنبعث منها ، ويمكنني الحصول على نتائج على بعد بوصة واحدة تكون رائعة جدًا على بعد ست بوصات ولن أحصل على أي تأثير إذا كنت لست حريصًا لأنك تعلم أنه يمكن التغلب على هذه الروبوتات لأنها عمومًا ستضعها في الغرفة لمدة 60 دقيقة ولذا فنحن لا نحاول الحصول على  لقد تم ذلك
في 10 ثوانٍ ، لدينا الآن قدرًا هائلاً
من الوقت ويمكننا فقط الاستمرار في تناول
الجرعات أو
الخفقان الذي يقول إن الروبوت الخاص به يمكن أن يستمر
لمدة ثلاث ساعات بشحنة
كاملة ويمكن أن يغطي ما يقرب من 20000 قدم مربع
في ذلك الوقت
بينما تظل الأسئلة قائمة حول ما إذا كان  سيتوقف هذا
سرًا 19 ، فهو يأمل في أن تتمكن الأشعة فوق البنفسجية
يومًا ما من استبدال
البخاخات والمطهرات فئة سيباستيان سي إن إن